March 23rd 2012 I was going to school in
Utah I was like a junior in college
studying international relations and I
was looking for an internship there is
we're just filming here I was on the
State Department website the State
Department is like the foreign ministry
in the United States and they had an
intro video like a promotional video
explaining their internship program and
it was very poorly done so in a weird
moment of I don't even know what got
into me I sent these people an email and
I said well I said some pretty mean
things I noticed the promo video you
guys are using is extremely poorly done
I would like to make a video that is
more attractive and helpful men 2012 me
was a weird me let me know if you would
like me to make something and submit it
I just think that this program could be
more attractive if the information was
presented in a more effective way is how
I put it
hold on a second this is 2012 okay I
didn't know very much about video in
2012 I wasn't making very good videos
that I was making stuff like this and
like this and it was just not very good
in addition I didn't know how to do
motion graphics I wanted to learn how to
do it but I didn't know how and yet Here
I am promising to make a promotional
video which was very likely going to be
all animation and I had no animation
skills that's not true actually to my
credit I had one animation under my belt
and it looked like this that's an owl
and his circle around the owl in it and
then it falls and then it goes down it
just down that was my one portfolio
piece okay so that's me in 2012 and yet
Here I am proposing to the State
Department that I'm going to make them a
promotional video that is quote
attractive and helpful okay cool so what
happens next they responded
enthusiastically and said yes if you can
make us a video
for free we would gladly take your video
and put it on our site in this moment
something happened in my brain i chalk
this up as one of the inflection points
in my life it's something that would
continue to happen throughout my career
and that would take my animation skills
from this to this I'm gonna call this
process this thing that happened a speed
boost just like in Mario Kart when
you're like cruising along and you see
those flashy arrows on the ground and
you like hit them and they speed boost
you forward it's like a hack it's like
it's something that gives you more speed
than you naturally have after I got that
email back from the State Department I
began to devour tutorials I began to
just focus on this video all day and all
night
I began to learn so much faster than I
ever learned before I called this what
was happening to me excited
accountability so after three weeks of
intense excited accountability I made
this video my first real motion graphic
project unless you count the owl which
was technically my first and it's pretty
dear to my heart love that whole let's
face it when it comes to internships
with the State Department not all
college students can afford to travel to
Washington DC or overseas okay I mean
it's not like great
I went from knowing nothing truly to
knowing a ton about mush graphics and
having got my hands dirty for the first
time and that was facilitated through
this excited accountability soon vsfs
will begin the micro volunteering
program
what's that US here's a problem when you
want to learn something new you become
passionate about it if you want to learn
to bake bread suddenly you have a super
high tolerance for reading about yeast
fermentation if you want to learn
photography suddenly you're able to sit
down and learn about shutter speed and
aperture these fairly boring principles
but now you suddenly have the attention
span of like a genius two weeks goes by
and suddenly that passion that tolerance
for boring stuff
thinner and thinner and you eventually
peter out this was me in 2012 I had made
it through a few weeks of learning this
stuff when my motivational fuel started
to burn up I started to feel less and
less inclined to actually sit through
the tutorials then I wrote that email I
got that response and this happened my
motivation was back my tank was full I
was going fast I had accountability I
was excited and suddenly my ability to
persist through this kind of difficult
process of learning increased like
tenfold so this is easier said than done
and a lot of people ask me like how do
you actually go about learning this
stuff yeah you've got the speed boost
yeah you have like the excited
motivation but like what do you actually
do to learn this if you don't have film
school or some sort of structure to
learn the answer to me and kind of the
key to my career when it comes to
learning this stuff has been the
Internet I have a really soft spot in my
heart for learning online and because of
that I reached out to Skillshare to
sponsor this video because Skillshare is
one of the sites that I've used over the
years to learn and refine my visual
storytelling skills co-share is like
this giant repository of tutorials it's
like 10 bucks a month and you get access
to like 25,000 tutorials if you want to
learn animation like I did in 2012 there
are tons and tons of tutorials on the
site that will teach you all different
aspects of animation there's one
specifically called animated
infographics and data visualization
which was kind of the style that I was I
was doing in that in 2012 it's really
good like quality teaching so if you're
kind of in a place right now where you
want to learn something new whether it's
animation or a million other skills
skill shows got like tons of different
topics then go click the link and if you
are one of the first 500 you will get
two months for free I mean you don't
have to pay and then after that it's 10
bucks a month go start learning stuff
[Music]
skill sure doesn't have any influence
over this video or what I say or
anything but they did want to partner
with me on this video because this is
something that I truly 100% believe in
and want other people to experience as
well travel abroad okay so am i
recommending that everyone reach out to
the State Department and offer to redo
their promo video no this is an example
that illustrates a point of putting
yourself in a situation of excited
accountability first let's talk about
what you need to make this situation
work it's right there within excited
accountability first you need to be
excited whatever situation you put
yourself in that's going to teach you
these skills you have to like be
interested in it you have to align with
whatever the message is or whatever the
project is that sort of passion and
excitement about the project is going to
be a key part of the fuel the other
aspect of this the other side of it is
the accountability part there needs to
be a good amount of pressure not like
the anxiety like fear-based pressure
like that's actually like a speed bump
not a speed boost I mean the type of
pressure that like you want to deliver
because you want to impress and if you
don't deliver you'll feel a little bit
like oh that's where pressure needs to
be there because that's gonna propel you
forward as well a good balance of
excitement and accountability or
pressure together will make a situation
that is primed for you to learn and to
have this speed boost so let me give you
some examples that aren't State
Department maybe you want to learn how
to cook so instead of just like telling
yourself okay I wanna learn how to code
you can invite a friend or some friends
over for a dinner party and you are
going to be the one to cook and you tell
them that if you are interested in the
cuisine or the dish that you're cooking
and you feel a little bit of pressure
because people are coming over to your
house suddenly you've just created a
situation of excited accountability
alright so let's step up the steaks one
more notch to a professional level let's
say you have some video skills but
they're not in the place that you can
actually go pitch like a brand or an
organization or a news outlet to make
video for them you don't have those
skills yet but you want to acquire them
in this case I suggest going to a
non-profit
or a group that doesn't have a ton of
marketing budget and say hey I will make
a video for you and you develop a kind
of a pseudo professional relationship
even though money's not changing hands
and it's not that professional the
stakes are not so high that if you don't
deliver you're like reneging on a
contract but they're high enough that
you want to deliver and suddenly you'll
be in that excited accountability
situation and here comes the speed boost
the last example I want to give you is
another one that comes from my
experience now we're talking summer of
2015
thanks to this excited accountability
process I had done it several times with
a bunch of different organizations I
hadn't learned quite a bit of skills and
I was able to get a legitimate job in
motion graphics eventually that led me
to getting a job at Vox where I was
doing motion graphics and animation I
wanted to take my skills to the next
level and specifically I really wanted
to get into doing documentaries I never
done documentaries I had never made a
legitimate like documentary out in the
field but I wanted to learn so I went to
my boss at Vox and I said hey what if I
went out and made an explainer like we
do here but I did it in the field
linking my camera and things getting
interviews and then animating on top of
that at that time box was a startup and
Joe my boss was like could you write it
and film it and edit it and animate it
all on your own and if so like go for it
and I was like ok so I pitched this Cuba
story and I was given some great support
from the people at box to be able to
have to do this experiment but the
message was very clear
you can do this but it needs to be good
meaning if we're gonna invest in this
new format that's a little bit costlier
to have you go travel to Cuba then it
has to be like worth the resources in
the summer of 2015 that familiar feeling
came upon me I remember I was sitting in
a hotel in Miami the night before I was
flying to Cuba there was two thousand
dollars in cash sitting on the bed
because in Cuba they don't take bank
cards so you have to like literally
bring a ton of cash which is terrifying
and I'm sitting there with this mandate
of if this isn't good it's not gonna
happen again
like 100% responsibility on the
situation that I've put myself in
excited yes I was definitely excited I
mean look at that face that's an excited
me but also accountable pressure
responsibility both of those things were
happening to me at the most extreme
levels that they had ever happened to me
in my life and there's something that I
can't even explain that's just like
spilling out of me I've now done this
process a bunch of times but this was
like the most intense so that night I
did what I had been doing for weeks up
into that moment which is downloading
videos videos that I really loved from
like Vimeo and YouTube downloading them
and opening them up in QuickTime and
watching them frame by frame and writing
down oh that edit was really fast and it
went from this angle to that angle oh
the guy moved his camera kind of like
this that was really interesting I'm
gonna do that in Cuba like a giant list
of exactly what I was gonna do to up my
skills because I was in this highly
motivated highly responsible and
accountable situation that learning was
sinking in I was learning in a whole new
way at the time I watched a Skillshare
course about Creative transitions like
how to move your camera around in these
kind of creative ways to build out
transitions in your videos and like I
was devouring this tutorial like knowing
that I was gonna have to use this stuff
in this situation that I'd put myself in
I learned so much I was so ready to go
to Cuba
perform in the end I made three videos
and they were the best videos I had ever
made in my life
that's was another inflection point for
me that Cuba trip I feel grateful to Vox
for giving me that opportunity Joe my
boss is very very like open to those
types of experiments and so I'm
incredibly grateful to Vox for that but
I'm also grateful for what happens to
the human brain when you feel that
excited accountability you can really
really learn a lot without the need of
school so thanks to Skillshare for
sponsoring this video but also thanks to
Skillshare for just being around for
being a repository of high-quality
learning on the internet for ten bucks a
month so that all of us can access it
again if you want to try Skillshare out
for two months for free you can click
the link down in the description and
just see if it like is interesting to
you good teaching and good learning
visual learning like you see on
Skillshare is a way to kind of help pave
that process and make it a little bit
easier so I hope this is helpful I would
love to hear your feedback about this
process and what we talked about today
and yeah I got to go back to editing
borders because there's just so much
borders to edit okay bye
[Music]